[Music]  do you know where you are right now I'm  in a drug trial what do you think is  wrong with you I'm sick I don't matter  what would you say this trial is showing  you about yourself this therapy now it's  not therapy it's science once you begin  to appreciate the structure of the mind  there's no reason to believe that  anything about us can't be changed pain  can be destroyed the mind can be solved  how many of your subjects have ended up  catatonic zero my head doesn't work  right I thought maybe these people could  fix me sounds stupid  that doesn't sound stupid to me okay  people let's begin  my mind is playing tricks  [Music]  [Applause]  this is a multi reality brain magic [ __ ]  I don't know what's real and what's not  [Music]  something's wrong what did you do every  time I separate them they just find  their way back together  not protecting those people in there  [Music]  [Music]